The GLSL language is sort of like the C language, which is kind of like
JavaScript anyway but simpler. Because vectors are so important in graphics,
the language also has vector support built in. This vertex shader computes the
diffuse Lambertian lighting component at each vertex. At the top you can see
the material color defined as a uniform as something the vertex shader uses as
an input. Similarly, the lights direction is passed in as a uniform. Vec3 means
a three-element vector. RGB for the color, XYZ for the lights direction. Next
is a varying color, vColor, which is an output color. We'll use this in the
fragment shader. The vertex shader is required to always output GL position.
Which is a predefined variable. This vector holds the clipping coordinates of
the vertex location on the screen. This next line normalizes the direction to
the light. This operation is done here more for convenience of the designer so
that the light direction does not have to be passed in normalized. You could
get rid of this line if you require that the light direction must be normalized
before being passed into this shader. The diffuse reflection model is computed
on this next line. We take the dot product of the vertex normal and the light.
We use the maximum function here to make sure the result is not negative. A
negative number happens when the surface is pointing away from the light. We
don't allow the light's contribution to be negative. That would be like light
sucking energy from the surface. The final line of the program itself computes
the output color, called vColor, by multiplying the color by the diffuse
contribution. The shader language is a lot like C or Javascript, but has some
nice, built in features. Here, we're multiplying a vector, the material color,
times a single value. The language knows to multiply each value of the color
vector by the diffuse value.